hey everybody it's Mike from waterflows
and welcome to today's video you know
today is actually Saturday January 7th
uh yesterday was uh Friday the 6th which
was non-farm perils and if you remember
right we had that big uh nice move to
the upside
um you know right after after the number
came up we rallied came off and once
cash opened it was basically Off to the
Races and on yesterday's video
I had talked about you know recognizing
a trend day early
because you know you want to get in on a
trend day as quickly as possible so
that's what I'm going to discuss about
today so if you haven't already please
subscribe to the channel you know and if
you find you get some value out of this
video uh be sure to like the video and
and make a positive comment down below
so if you remember right non-farm
payrolls came up Market shot up cash
opened we started pulling back down uh
towards our low of the day we didn't
quite get there you know I believe our
lowest that time was uh made just before
the number came out but uh you know we
got down sort of I don't say tested it
but then we shot up from that low okay
now one of the ways that I like to use
order flow to determine if we are
experience seeing a trend day is I like
to look for Delta divergences okay
especially you know Delta divergences in
the order flow now when I'm looking at
Delta divergences I'm really looking at
them to occur during the cash open but
just really briefly what is a Delta
Divergence well
what you have is a Divergence between
Delta and the bar and price so
take it a step further if you're at a
new high or equal high of the day as you
can see we hit this High here this was
38 76 and a quarter we have a negative
Delta minus 1088 okay
so you're at your high of the day and
you have negative Delta right that that
is your order flow Delta Divergence now
with my software we added an extra
feature in there you have to be closing
down price action of the bar also has to
be going down so what that means is you
have to have a new or equal High you
have to have negative Delta and the bar
has to be a red bar right because some
people will qualify a Divergence as
I don't know if there was one here not
yet uh
you know a new or equal High
with negative Delta but they don't take
into account the bar collar right like
here you got the negative Delta and the
new High they'll say well this is a
Divergence I've just found you know in
my many years of trading that for me is
fundamentally wrong because if you're
looking to get short off of a high price
action also has to be negative Okay so
if you have my software
we have a setting for this actually it's
called the Delta Divergence and it's
just right up here near the top
um if it's enabled you know I'll draw
the software will draw a gold sort of
box at the top obviously there'll be a
gold Arrow you could draw it fixed or
until tested I just like to keep it
fixed and so what I'm looking for are
these bars that have the gold down
triangle
at the high of the day or if it was the
low of the day right it would be
um you know let's see just just give you
an example of one
as we're going lower let me see here
okay here right this is a Delta
Divergence Buy Signal now again you can
adjust the colors maybe you want it to
be a bluish color right blue is sort of
the universal for by signals or green
um but I just you know Delta Divergence
I I know that if it's coming in at a low
it's a Buy Signal if it's coming in at a
high it's a sell signal so I don't
really need to have different colors per
se but what I'm looking for okay is I'm
looking for a group of divergences
within a relatively short period of time
that are going to be failing and what do
I mean by failing is taken out so we got
one here at 9 43 right I can see this
gold
um at the top of the bar with the red
down triangle obviously it's negative
Delta you have
you know the red candle down it's the
new high so that's a Delta Divergence by
my definition we have another one here
first one 943 next one 957 then the next
one at 1004.
okay so all I do when I get three
come in as soon as I see the third one
you know mentally I'm thinking
okay we're in a trend driven Market
because I've had three which are
normally bearish signals right when you
have a Delta Divergence by itself it's
usually
you're telling you that they're selling
coming in however
right I've got
this Market is sort of rejecting that
selling in a sense
what's happening is right we're making
new highs yeah some selling comes in
very quickly come out take out those
High some more selling comes in very
quickly take out that high right one two
three this happened in basically from 9
43 to 1004 so you know about 20 minutes
so 20 minutes it's rejected basically
three highs of the day and by when I say
rejected what I mean is it's taking them
out meaning that these Highs are
not strong so meaning to me there's
probably going to be higher Highs coming
in okay and so I'm just drawing this
line here 38.93 I just put a buy stop up
here at three and a quarter because I've
seen it enough when I get these groups
of
Delta divergences within a short period
of time people say oh how short well I
like an hour right during the the normal
session I like to give it about an hour
you know 30 minutes even better but you
know I don't want to say over the course
of the trading day
or you know five hours or for us you
know within an hour but again it's not
hard and fast rule that it's got to be
an hour if it came in at an hour and one
minute yeah I'd still take it right
sometimes you know people like to be so
precise well you know Mike said one hour
this is coming in at one hour and two
minutes I can't take it no you can okay
so 38.90
uh three and a quarter here basically
just right above this high is where
you'd be looking to buy
and almost immediately comes right back
up
three and a quarter trade all the way to
97 get another Divergence okay okay it
starts coming off again actually pulls
back down to here we got down to what 86
and a quarter now remember this you're
trying to determine what type of trading
day you're in right is this a trend
driven day
which is basically a flow driven Day
meaning what a flow driven day is you
have much longer time frame Traders
right if you follow Market profile
volume profile the other otfs right the
other time frame Traders coming into the
market the ones that have the Deep
Pockets that are going to hold so I'm
not putting it in I'm not getting long
here at you know three and a quarter
with a simple
um two-point stop right I know that if
this is a trend day
there could be a lot more to this move
so even getting a bit of a pullback Down
to You Know six and a quarter
is it you know enough to really get me
panicked over it now you know on on the
chart here where was it here
um 90
this High where was it here 93 I'll just
draw the line here 90. well I'll draw
the line This is 93 here so 93 and a
quarter
let's draw that line here so
93 and a quarter is basically My Line in
the Sand okay from 93 and a quarter the
rest of the trading day because this is
a trade I'm looking to hold because I'm
already making this decision that we're
in a flow driven Market that this Market
can keep going up right the rest of the
trading day
and so I'm not going to be spooked out
by a little pullback down to you know 86
a quarter even here 85 and then you know
we go up and sort of pull back again
down towards you know six and a half and
then keep going because I'm looking for
this move here oftentimes this move here
is going to happen
relatively sooner in this case it took
some time didn't happen until you know
12 30 that you got that move
um but again I'm not I'm not when when
you're trying to you know the best place
to get into a trend is as obviously as
early as possible the second best time
is is now but so you know what I'd like
to got in earlier yeah I would have but
you can only trade what the market is
giving you if it's telling you hey you
know what we're we're in the middle of a
of a trending now again you know this
day we did have that big economic data
that came out
so
you know Market is a bit volatile it's
unfortunate it just came in you know
much higher than where it was earlier so
you know that's what I'm looking at when
I'm looking at determining a trend day
okay now again you know there's other
tools that you can use
um you know some Traders I know like to
use things like initial balance let's
throw initial balance on here real quick
I have the initial balance uh indicator
from Ninja caters
um
I'll just add you know the first hour of
trading just add it in here show you
what it looks like you know here okay so
yeah I mean we're breaking out of the
initial balance we hit
the first range extension here as well
so you know all signs are there of a of
a potential Trend day
um
you know one of the other things I like
to look at as well you know obviously
you know there's a lot of bullish
indicators that were just everything was
sort of flashing
um on Friday
anchored view app
anchored view app right I I I'm not
necessarily a huge fan of v-wap but one
of the view apps I will use is an
anchored V web I like to Anchor it from
important periods of time in one of the
places well there's a couple places
obviously the number right when it came
out 7 30. I'm not really interested this
is 7 30 here I'm not really interested
in everything that happened before in
terms of view app I'm interested in what
happens after the number okay so y'all
anchored from there again it's not
really showing me but you can adjust
your anken re-wap right it's just you
know if you're sailing in a boat right
you lift up anchor you find someone else
somewhere else to go
um you know the high after the number
came out but then more importantly I
like to look at what's happening during
the cast cash
session tongue twister there and you
know here's the cache okay what do I got
I got a high and a low after the cash
made okay so we're starting to go up so
I'm going to Anchor it from the low
okay and you can see it's holding that V
web quite nicely all right and it's
making a nice move up
um
you know so you got initial balance you
know there's other things that you could
look at obviously you know you could add
um you know you could add some
profiles if you like
um you know onto here let's add a
let's add a profile on here sort of a
dynamic profile and Cat where am I here
profile well this profile box
oh yeah here and Cat profile box I'll
add this really quick here
Okay add a profile box again you know if
you wanted to add it from
you know
obviously the low
here obviously we're no trading out
above I I like to use a profile box and
just sort of you know I'm always looking
at you know is there any sort of signs
here in the market that is telling me
you know there's something more to this
move here
okay you know draw it from the low up to
this High okay from the low of cash to
this new high up here I could see my
value area high is here we started
coming back into it this value area high
is up near the top of the bar Act of
this profile actually
um and it's kind of holding there right
again you know if you're going to draw
out you know once you make a new high
draw it out and you can see as you know
the nice thing about a flexible profile
like this if you're drawing it out right
you could just make note of
what
what point of control is doing that's
your first point of control when you hit
this High here okay then you come up
here I'll use this High here
okay where's
point of control is coming in right here
okay
point of control
is coming in
here
okay so you know as the day is expanding
or more trading is taking place you can
see the point of controls one two three
obviously going higher over the course
of the day that's another sign of a
market that is trending you know any of
these signs again you know this day was
non-farm payroll day a lot of volatility
so you have all this
earlier action but if this is like a
normal trading day that started here
you'd be looking for the same things
you'd be looking for you know is the
what's the market doing at the highs is
it taking out divergences is
um you know the view app
you know obviously you're going higher
curve is going to be up that's simple
but you know
when it pulls back is it pulling back to
the view app or is it just having very
short dips to the Anchor V web again
this is an anchored view app it's not a
vlap for the day I'm anchoring it from
the low of the cast session
you know what's point of control right
as I expand the profile up from a low
the low of the cash session what's it
doing
okay and you can just see the profile I
mean the snapshot basically over the
course of the day here's your
volume okay
it's still there same level
again we still got that volume there now
where it gets in stream you come up here
get that big distribution coming and now
you're starting to form a double
distribution in the volume
okay and you know that if you're forming
another double distribution that's what
a trend day looks right you're looking
for that
double distribution form to be
printing in a sense you know being made
and you can see it's just being made and
you know but by then you should already
be convinced once you're trading up in
you know in the 90s that this is a trend
day okay so again these are some of the
things I look for on a trend day
ideally you know you want to spot a
trend day as as early as possible
you know I'll say I wish there was
something in the order flow that really
would have given me a much better sign
in the order flow earlier like you know
when we're trading 50 or 60 but you know
we had a lot of volatility on Friday
okay so but there was still more to the
move to be had you know again you know
we got all the way up into
um you know the high 20s but again you
know if you're buying it at 90s and
you're selling it in the teens or even
in the 20s that's still a good trade
okay it's not about catching the move
from down here at 40. yeah
congratulations if you bought it there
and then you sold it you know above 3
900 that's a fantastic trade pat
yourself on the back but
you know you just got to go with what
the order flow is telling you sometimes
and unfortunately it just we had that
volatility that
it took a while for something really
solid to determine that the trend was
happening
all right everyone so again I hope you
guys found this video useful um if you
did be sure to subscribe to the channel
and and you know like the video thanks
everyone bye-bye